and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist because optimal health is
real wealth Ryan amen
today we're gonna talk about making
simple choices to improve your overall
wellness with our guest dr. Ryan green
from monarch athletic club in West
Hollywood California
doc green thanks for being here mm man
one of our favorite human beings on the
planet is here yeah my favorite doctor
by far I've ever had
Marley because he's like the healthiest
doctor I've ever had what isn't that
weird he'll let you go to doctors
sometimes and I had to go have a
colonoscopy earlier this year and great
guy very kind but he was like kind of
obese and I didn't have necessarily the
best recommendations for me he was
really good at actually doing the
colonoscopy at least I think he was now
now doc you are you're really healthy
but also you got into functional
medicine I think for a reason yeah
absolutely so as a medical student
resident fellow
I experienced the same things that you
did so on my mentorships rotations and
things like that I interacted with my
attendings mentors and whatnot and I saw
the same things that you did these
people were coming in they were living
unhealthy lives making poor health
choices and I always thought it was a
kind of an odd paradigm for someone to
come in who's ill and then take advice
from someone who was also relatively
unwell and when I was going through my
training I'd always wanted to be a
sports medicine team physician for a
professional sports team but for a
multitude of reasons one being it's a
volunteer effort and a lot of people
don't know that so you end up having two
full-time jobs one of the things that
you have a difficult time appreciating
is that a lot of people not only those
that come to you but also those that are
providing the information are not well
and so we have to do a comprehensive
retool of our system if we are going to
see tangible and objective improvement
in our health and wellness because right
now we're on a path for
you know collapse in somewhat of a
doomsday type approach based on how much
we spend on chronic modifiable disease
well you were you were at the the the
Mayo Clinic Frieden residency and some
Dartmouth did my residency at arms oh
okay and you you were so you were at the
Mayo Clinic and and one thing I remember
you said to me was like I realize like
quite often what I would do during in
the Mayo Clinic or at residency was like
people would come in and we'd make them
just well enough to go out and be unwell
I sure yeah absolutely and that's I had
to go to not the emergency room but
Urgent Care relatively recently and I
noticed that like it's it's sort of like
it's just just different variations of
band-aids in many ways yeah I mean the
fact the matter is people don't treat
another individual to say hey I'm gonna
get you 50 percent better but the fact
of the matter is hospitals or businesses
they have to generate revenue because
they have to function so the underlying
foundation of our current system is
volume turnover patients and patients
out how do you minimalize hospital stays
because insurance companies don't want
to pay for extra nights in the hospital
so they encourage the practitioners and
they value them based on their ability
not only to treat but also to treat
concisely so that you can get people in
people out hospital system makes money
insurance companies don't have to spend
a lot of money and ultimately we're all
in the same pool in a symbiotic
relationship so you have to appreciate
that that is a significantly strong
underlying current in our current system
that's unlike any other country in the
world where prevention tends to be a
little bit more of something that takes
precedence but for us it's much more of
a reactive space its signature as
opposed to healthcare yeah that's that's
unfortunate it's like they focus on how
much money can you make per patient not
how well are your patients when they
leave the hospital
I think what's what's important I love
all of this doc is you talk about making
simple choices there is a lot of
complexity here but we can simplify and
I hope to do that today we got a bunch
of questions from our audience so let's
start there cat in Arkansas something
that I've heard you guys talked
if that splittin function a little bit
would be overweight or y'all were
younger and as a person I delicious up
and I struggle with deeply and I do
think that food is a type of consumption
so what I've asked you if you guys would
talk about how food fits into your
middle life lifestyle and if you would
provide is on how to have a healthy
relationship so doc it sounds like she's
asking how do I create and maintain I
think that word maintain is important a
healthy relationship with food I Ryan
and I we often joke it but it's the
truth we were the two fattest kids when
we met in fifth grade Wow in school I
mean I was 11 we tell people that they
look at Josh and they're like you used
to be fat cause I got up to 265 pounds
in college I stopped playing soccer and
I was in love with beer and Qdoba wow
did yes I mean I feel you I feel other
people's pain because I I did definitely
deviated from everything that I've
indoctrinated into my day to day now
mm-hmm so I'm not that kind of person
that's never struggled with any of these
problems like I've I have absolutely
experienced some of that stuff well yeah
I mean at that weight that's considered
obese I was obese Ryan was open so we
all three of us have struggled with that
at some point you were less radical than
me and I really appreciate that about
you actually remind me a lot of my wife
where you take a more balanced approach
I'd love to hear about you a lie about
about establishing and maintaining a
healthy relationship with food sure yeah
absolutely it's tough what people may or
may not realize but at the end of the
day it is true from the earliest
memories that we have were inundated
with information about eating foods that
are essentially addictive that are
sugar-laden so we developed these
patterns at a young age that are
difficult to deviate from you know that
being said you don't have to deprive
yourself of things that bring you joy
right you got to live a little yeah and
the next you know component of that is
there are many healthy things that taste
great
food should not be a punishment and by
any means ultimately it will require a
little bit of dedication and time on the
individuals end to say hey how can I
develop that relationship through
cooking myself or making the healthy
choices and say hey it's easy to go post
mates something quickly that's
relatively unhealthy or I could take the
time to prepare or I could choose
something that's a little bit more
costly but ultimately a little bit
healthier because in the long run
there's data that shows an individual
who's overweight overweight with
diabetes will spend anywhere from eight
to fifteen thousand dollars more per
year on health related cost Wow
so I try to tell people in patients you
know here's the deal whether it's
shopping at Whole Foods or choosing a
healthier to go option yeah on the back
end you're saving yourself time money
lost productivity and work or connected
it that way connection with another
individual because you're making a
healthier choice yeah because you can
eat McDonald's you know you could spend
five bucks a day and eat five double
cheeseburgers correct and you'll sustain
yourself and live but at what cost I
mean you end up spending a lot more in a
weird thing about that is like you
mentioned like some of these things
might bring you joy but I quite I find
like when I was really just morbidly
obese I wasn't actually getting the joy
that I thought I was getting momentary
sort of ephemeral gustatory pleasure
I was actually in the break room the
other day here and I saw this guy who
was over certainly overweight and he had
a whole pizza in front of him and he's
just watching his phone like mindlessly
shoving Pizza I totally get it cuz that
I was there I was there but wasn't
enjoying at all in fact he didn't look
depressed he kind of looked defeated
like wow this is and he it didn't look
like he was nourishing himself it's just
like you you're programming yourself - I
have to I have to just put this in and I
think the key is not to just say well
I'm not gonna have any of that
it's what am I gonna replace this with
whether it's you know organic fruits and
vegetables having a big salad for lunch
or grass-fed grass-finished meteor and
and finding alternative
to replace that I mean essentially that
junk food with yeah it's so true and you
know you talked about the commitment
that it takes to start eating healthy
I'll tell you like the first so last
year when you told me I was like on the
verge of having type 2 diabetes like I
had to cut out a ton of sugar I had to
cut out a ton of just really bad carbs
and I mean that was hard for two reasons
like a I was addicted but B I grew up
victimizing sugar or I'm sorry
victimizing fat not not the sugar and
it's taking me the last five or six
years to really understand that that is
the you know the FDA with you know sugar
lobbyists that are telling us like oh
that's bad you need to eat our low-fat
stuff which just ends up being sure high
and sugar but those first like two weeks
even the first month like we were in
Australia and like dude I would get
hangry and I mean like hangry in the
true sense of life pissed off don't talk
to me like my blood sugar is low and
it'd be easy to like grab you know
something quick and something convenient
but I mean there was you know a month of
discomfort I had to go through here for
my body started to not crave those
sugars it's an addiction it's literally
an addiction we're feeling withdrawal
from years of a certain behavior and
anyone who's successful at anything in
life will appreciate that it takes time
and dedication to develop the
appropriate practices to be successful
in anything very rarely are people
Superstars from the first attempt right
at anything and it's the same thing with
food so if you've struggled with it just
appreciate it's going to take time to
develop those habits number one number
two having a support system of people
that are going to hold you accountable
is very beneficial and then just from a
food perspective and I'm not the first
person to say this I think Michael
Pollan was you know eat real food if
it's in a package it's probably been
processed so try to choose things that
are local organic when you can
sustainably grown I mean we're in
California so we have more farmers
markets I think per capita than anywhere
in the United States so you have the
ability to obtain those items you just
have to take time you have to plan a
little bit and even if you can't for
whatever reason there are still numerous
options that you can you know patronize
that will
you to eat those healthy items a little
bit more expensive certainly but at the
end of the day it's understanding your
long term longevity as well as what
you're actually going to the absolute
value of what you'll spend on health
care will be minimized because you are
making those healthy choices on the
front end okay for an hour you'll pay
for a lot of percent so just real quick
cat I just want to kind of reframe this
for you um you know don't eat out of
convenience like that's a problem if
you're struggling with you know your
diet and being overweight yeah don't eat
out of convenience that's gonna hurt you
in the long run the other thing I want
to encourage you to do also cat is what
dr. Ryan was saying like go out and get
good foods and bring him into the house
if you're bringing in sugary foods
oh I'm just good because this is what I
do I'll get like you know a little some
kind of treat and I'm like oh I'll just
have a couple bites a day or a little
piece of date and then it's gone by the
end of the day ate the whole jar of
peanut butter right exactly Red's come
by the next day so so make sure you're
bringing in healthy foods to your house
I mean the more healthy options you have
the less unhealthy options you have
you're going to have a healthier diet
for sure can't understand you a copy of
our book minimalism because in there we
talked about the five foundational
values in life and one of those is
health in fact it's the first one
because we don't have your health you
really don't have anything and the
richest man in the world who is
unhealthy but what does the Confucian
Confucius said the healthy man wants ten
thousand things the unhealthy man wants
one and I really feel that way about
about our health and Ryan and I wrote
about some principles with respect to
health that I think will really help you
out and also I think you'll find value
in the rest of this episode as well
Shawn if you reach out to Kat send her a
copy of minimalism live a meaningful
life I feel like our podcast you like
the audiobook version of that or if you
want the book book or the ebook we're
happy to send those to you as well Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do we are at the
minimalists on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and dr. Ryan Greene is at doctor
underscore green your score green
underscore TFE oh there we go well if
you can't remember that we'll put a link
to it in the show notes as well yeah
we'll put a length of that so you can
definitely find it in the show notes
what's our first question Ryan our first
question is from Matthew what
unintuitive small lifestyle change
make the biggest impact on overall
health so I'm gonna give you a pithy
answer here
by the way doctoring what we try to do
is we try to give some short answers
that are treatable and retweet Abul but
we can just ramble on a little bit so
yeah Sean mix it up in post and make it
real nice and editing makes all of our
answers make some real pretty put some
of the show notes and then Jessica puts
them at minimal maxims calm as well my
short answer is granular changes produce
grandiose results I think too often we
try to make 180 degree pivot sure
overnight I'm gonna change everything
I'll throw it all out I'm going vegan
I'm going carnivore I'm going blah but
whatever and it's like well no you can
make a 5 degree pivot and you're a
totally different destination you're
here from now yeah yeah 1% for me
circadian rhythms are huge for people
that don't know it's essentially how
your body works is based on light and
dark mm-hmm for thousands of years we
operated based on what you could do when
there is visible light and then not
visible light and the body has adapted
appropriately so just doing the same
thing every day developing those
patterns that you know that you can
repeat whether it's hydration exercise
when you're eating when you're sleeping
those are all simple changes that you
don't have to pay money for someone to
allow you to adopt and you will notice
that the more repeatable your day is the
better your body functions yeah amen
well often told me most medicine is free
lately whether you're going to the the
sauna or your cold plunge cryotherapy
well crowd therapy isn't free no but
it's relatively inexpensive if you're if
you're what you're trying to do here is
take care of your body sleep exercise
most of these things are actually free
oh yes I do I love what you said when
you were talking about when you're
responding the cats question you said
move eat well recover like that is
that's pretty simple advice and that's
what we do here at the minimalist we
give simple advice now simple isn't easy
yeah but it certainly is a great advice
and that kind of leads into my pithy
answer which is when in doubt go for a
walk I mean if you're sitting around
you're like oh what should I be doing
should I be doing crunches should I go
to the gym like just skip and go for a
walk I mean you've got to move that's
what's gonna help you yeah I exercise
every day but it generally means I walk
about eight miles a day and then I'll do
some push it up some pull up some some
squats
and that's that's enough for me all
right our next question is from grant
what is the optimal what is the optimal
amount of time a person should work out
each week well my short answer is what's
optimal for one man is suboptimal for
another and so like doc green and I work
out differently for sure I just said I
do push-ups pull-ups squats he's like
doing Crossfit and like I you doing all
kinds of things I'm with him a few times
it's hard to keep up yeah I think it's
it's about moving every day though right
hundred percent I'll give you the
textbook definition American Heart
Association says 150 minutes of moderate
to high intensity activity okay
per week so it's 30 minutes a day five
days a week based I've moderate to high
intensity so you got a sweat it's great
for your body 80% of Americans do not
achieve that minimum activity guideline
so you don't have to do SoulCycle you
don't have to do CrossFit anything like
that but you got to do something that
elevates your heart rate to the point
that it stresses your body so Fitness is
literally activity beyond your normal
day-to-day don't care what it is
everyone's is different but you got it
you have to find that point where you're
breathless where you're sweating and try
to get 30 minutes a day five or six days
a week and you will notice your body
performs much better my pithy answers
don't forsake quality for quantity so
what I mean by that is in correct me if
I'm wrong here man like for me if I'm
thinking I'm someone who doesn't
exercise at all and then I hear exercise
five days a week for 30 minutes high
intensity I will never just jump into
that so you know for someone who's that
level zero right now it's like don't
worry about how many times you're
exercising per week just get out there
and start moving start start doing
something like even if you're doing it
only two days a week that's better than
no days a we sure yeah everyone has to
start somewhere
ultimately we have a threshold that we
would love everyone to achieve but
you're right you have to start somewhere
and walking versus sitting hiking versus
you know just whatever you're doing day
to day ultimately will improve your ya
know for all function well and I think
it you know ultimately like you when you
start to incorporate these healthy
habits with exercise like you eventually
will start to build on top of it
like I find myself now where I'll get up
and do the peloton and then I'll go to
the gym later in the afternoon so
sometimes I'll get to work two workouts
in the rink but I certainly didn't start
there sure it helped baguettes greater
health mmm our question next is from
Nikki how can I overcome sugar cravings
I eat healthy meals for the most part
but have huge issues with sugar
especially chocolate you know I think
this isn't my pity answer but for the
most part is the problem yeah you can
probably tweet that podcast shot I mean
because that's that's my problem right
lay-oh yeah I do that for the most part
it where like I teach a writing class
and and one of the things like that yeah
I write everyday for the most part
people say I'm like no you're gonna
write for an hour every single day while
you're taking my write for the most part
is 51% and so my short answer here is
food is nourishment not entertainment
now now I will append that by saying you
can enjoy food still but I'd like to
think of it first as nourishment when I
saw the guy stuffing the pizza in his
face watching whatever he was watching
on Netflix like that was that was like
he was entertaining himself with it like
gustatory but like he wasn't really
nourishing himself and I want to look at
food first as is this nourishing my body
my day my mind and then you can find
ways to enjoy it now I find usually the
meals I enjoy most are the meals that I
share with other people absolutely you
know it's funny I used to use that food
as entertainment as an excuse to eat
unhealthy like for me well when I was
vegan for a year on a bet and won the
bet by the way Josh still owes me a
dollar
I found that Oreos were vegan so like
Oreo does this amazing marketing tactic
where they like try or mint Oreos try
your special limited-edition candy cane
Christmas Oreos and I would always be
like oh here's like something that's
kind of cool and entertaining and it's
only around a certain time of year so I
got to buy it and eat it and I fell into
that trap of yes using entertainment as
an excuse so can a meal be entertaining
yeah I think there are certainly meals
that can be some amazing experiences but
yeah you're right Josh it's usually the
company that you're enjoying with the
meal it's not the food itself but we do
fall into that trap of looking at oh
well that's
that's only around for a certain limit
at a time that looks like it'll be you
know a good meal experience and then we
use it as an excuse to eat unhealthy
dark-green you help out with the menu
over at Takaya I do and you're not just
pouring sugar into a bunch of things to
make cabinets no heavens no here's the
thing food tastes good because there's
fat in it
mmm if you eliminate the natural fats
that are in many different foods it's
not going to taste well and that's where
we did ourselves a disservice like you
mentioned previously we vilified fat
supplemented with sugar and now we are
where we are with regards to the the
viewers question chocolate has a lot of
health benefits but it's the type of
chocolate so don't feel bad about
chocolate consumption there's a lot of
people out there it's a weakness just
make sure you're looking for something
that has 71 percent or greater cacao
it's a darker chocolate it's a little
bit bitter take some getting used to but
ultimately you can pacify that chocolate
craving and still do yourself a positive
benefit my favorite brand is prions -
it's called fruition now yeah if you can
put a link to the 100% bars you don't
have to do 100% they have they have
probably a 72% it's really high quality
you can get an Amazon now four bucks a
bar yeah it's like one square after a
meal and yeah there's this hundred
percent that Trader Joe's has called I
think it's Montezuma and that chocolate
for it's 100 percent it has some cocoa
nibs in there so it's almost like a
healthy like crunch bar yeah it took me
forever to get actually it wasn't
forever
took me a couple weeks to get used to
but like now I look forward to that 100%
dark chocolate and every time I have
something that lets say just like 60 or
70 percent like it's super super sweet
to me now so your body does it just so
Nikki yeah get darker chocolate for your
chocolate cravings your body will
definitely adjust to it my pet the
answer is this if you want to quit
something stop surrounding yourself with
it so if you're gonna bring in again
you're gonna bring in those treats
you're gonna bring in unhealthy foods to
your house Nikki like you're gonna cave
in and you're gonna eat it because it's
there yeah so that's that's one way you
can definitely help overcome their sugar
cravings is stop bringing the sugar into
the house get the sugar out because if
you're breaking the addiction you don't
want to have heroin all over the house
either right or you don't want to hang
out with people who are doing heroin I
mean
it's I know it's hard sometimes like
even here at the at we work like they'll
have like Oh someone brought in taffy
and there's like a baguette taffy on the
table and I just have to like put my
blinders on and like walk past it but
even you know it works sometimes you get
tempted with it but you know if you
couldn't you can you at least have the
ability to control what sugar comes into
your house and and you can certainly
make some some advancements there can
add one more component yeah do I talk to
patients all the time about this it's
not a pithy answer you guys are better
at that than I am but here's the deal
breakdown the year 365 days if you have
a quote unquote cheat day which is like
such a popular term these days once a
week 52 days out of the year you're
essentially not nourishing your body for
almost 20% of the year so if you walked
into an exam in school and your teacher
said the maximum score you can achieve
is 80% b-minus would people be okay with
that
probably not really do good for all the
other 80 blonde Ajitha when I was at
Mayo Clinic brief tangent everyone had a
birthday or some reason to celebrate and
it's not Mayo Clinic's fault but in the
break room there's always cake there's
always punch from 9 a.m. till you know
whatever it was gone and you walk
through there and you're like you know
what I can have a little square a little
corner and you end up to half three or
four days a week and then before you
know it like why can't I achieve this
goal and you're like well you're
undermining yourself and you don't even
appreciate it yeah it reminds me the
jackal willing quote like if you're if
you go and you're like do you want the
cake or the pie and you're like well
there's the third option the third
option is to have neither neither dude
yeah I want a Sean please put in the the
show notes that jaco willing or what is
his last name willingly yeah Jaakko
willing that the album that he has
essentially on iTunes
but it's great like if you need
motivation to like eat healthier to or
to not eat unhealthy put the doughnut
down yeah put the doughnut down it's
poison it's so good like it's yeah I
would recommend that Nikki like download
that album and then every time you got
that craving just listen to a couple of
those those tracks that he has and
hopefully it'll change your state a
little bit that's a really good added
value for the day alright it looks like
we got a bunch more surprise questions
this week questions about appetite about
supplements about EMF
an artificial light exposure questions
about stress and fasting and our mitten
fasting tips for improving sleep also
exercise at dr. greens monarch Athletic
Club and much much more with dr. Ryan
green also 27 health and nutrition tips
that are actually evidence-based and
we've got this hilarious article from
James Olsen super funny I haven't
laughed that hard in a while five
reasons I don't go to doctors and we're
gonna check that out if you want to hear
all that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I and well this
week dr. Ryan green and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and I well three of us we
recorded entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about a
bunch of stuff we don't usually discuss
in public plus patreon is the best way
for us to fund this podcast and keep it
100% advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app and also on patreon we're doing ask
the minimalist anything we're doing a
special health version with dr. green as
well so you're gonna get like a
quadruple dose of dr. green this week
you can check that out oh and we're
capping our patreon supporters 6,000
people now we've decided that's enough
so there are some spots left but once we
have 6,000 people then it's all full
shutting the door yeah we're gonna close
the door and talk to the small audience
over on patreon you can find all that
all the details all the good stuff
including an additional private podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists com slash support Nicodemus
what else you got for us this week being
informed is more important than ever
especially when it comes to health
topics so get out there read more I mean
Josh and I I mean we are not doctors
luckily we have a doctor here to answer
these health questions but you know you
want to get more of a diverse opinion
than just dr. Ryan green he's got a
great opinion but get out there and read
more and get informed and now here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners hi Josh and Ryan just a
few tips about your
listeners and also things I've learned
on the way let your kids wear heirloom
jewelry and play dress-up have a tea
party or a candlelight dinner
you'll make memories and bring meaning
by doing so you can frame the jewelry in
a shadow box and display it as art IKEA
is a great resource they're a nice way
to edit collections or honor the memory
of a loved one by framing their mementos
and pictures in a small contained space
I found useful sentimental items brought
me the most meaning I cook with my mom's
wooden spoon daily and warn my kids with
the Afghan my grandma knit I'm finally
donating the China I've kept in a box
for 20-plus years because I realized it
won't have any meaning or relevance for
my daughters since I never used it
Replacements calm as a resource to sell
china and silverware for everyday
practical items buy quality and
aesthetically pleasing once buy the
flowery nail clippers if people won't
stop giving you things swing by goodwill
on your way home and get a receipt treat
it like candy don't even bring it into
your house find resources online for
recycling pay for postage as if it means
that much but give yourself permission
to toss these items those items that
won't be donated while you're
establishing a baseline you'll be
causing much less in the future wean off
shopping by going to thrift stores and
yard sales always have a list of needs
remember dollar spent is still a dollar
spent and even free might come with a
price I've been known to replace all the
items in my cart back to their
respective places treating each as if
the hunch was satisfying enough and
feeling empowered by asking the hard
questions and making the conscious
choice not to possess it take a picture
if you want to remember it take pictures
of your kids art and make a book turn
old t-shirts into quilts or pillows for
everyone excuse me one new thing rid
yourself of two things two libraries are
cropping up for borrowing tools if you
don't have one start one volunteer at
hands-on network org register click to
sign up and then show up when we lost
our business and house and filed
bankruptcy we volunteered when my
husband died in an accident three years
later we volunteered don't underestimate
the power of giving to and doing for
others for me passion equals pressure
instead I'm following my curiosities and
my love of learning if that leads to a
passion then that's great and if not
that's okay too because I will have
learned a lot along the way hi my name
is Michelle and from Edmonton Alberta
Canada I just saw a comment about the
recent health podcast and I just want to
say that one thing that I have found has
been really helpful for me with
increasing my fitness in kind of like a
minimalist way has been basically making
my body a vehicle you know I live in an
image in Alberta so we have winters and
summers and Falls and you know I I used
to rely on my car a lot just to get me
everywhere whereas now I buy in the
summer time pretty much from April 1 to
October 31 weather permits and in the
winter I take the bus and that has made
a huge difference for me because I get
some type of physical exercise every
single day and what I love about cycling
in the summer is just the mental health
that I gain as well because I see the
Sun Rise every morning and I get to
experience nature and I just even if I'm
having a really busy work or family life
I don't feel like I'm missing out on
decision because I'm cycling I'm getting
outdoors every day and and the best part
about that is is for my daughter because
she is a part of that and and she loves
going for bike rides with mommy and she
loves going to stroller rides in the
winter or going for sleigh rides to
daycare every morning and you know so
it's become a real family affair and I
encourage anybody to just think about
their body as a vehicle and maybe in
this process you may realize you don't
even need a car which is something that
my husband and I are actually evaluating
right now we're actually seriously
considering not even owning a car
anymore so yeah that's what I recommend
for everyone to think about thank you
alright y'all thanks again to dr. Ryan
Green make sure you find him on
Instagram it's dr. underscore green
underscore do but you can find that in
our show notes as well they can also
find monarch athletic club at monarch
WeHo com is that right that's correct
and you said you want to go your email
address if people have
questions yeah absolutely it's ours and
Roger gr EE n is an ANSI e my last name
has an e at the end of it it's the
proper spelling so our green yeah
monarch mo na r CH weh o calm feel free
to reach out I'll get back to y'all cool
we'll put down the show notes super
beautiful thank you so much for being
here today appreciate you we love you we
care about you we're grateful for you
real quick for right here right now
here's one things going on in the life
of the minimalist so I teach a writing
class online we're all writers now yeah
the I solved this study a few years ago
we are actually the most literate
generation ever it doesn't seem that way
because we're we're like we're talking
in emojis and everything else but you
have to think a few generations ago our
grandparents quite often the last
paragraph they wrote in their life there
were 18 years old they left high school
and they went to go work with a factory
and never wrote another paragraph after
that and and so now we're literally
writing every day whether it's text
messages or tweets or Facebook posts or
Instagram captions or blog posts or
maybe you want to write the next great
American novel or you want to write your
own book we are all writers now and I
have a writing class I've had everyone
from medical doctors take the class to
high school students and everyone in
between because I believe a rising tide
lifts all boats so if you want to learn
how to write better the writing class
that I teach is called how to write
better and you can find out more about
that at how to write better or get is a
four-week class where I help you learn
the sort of fundamentals and the habits
of how to write better and if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for 0 6
2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
e-mail list over at the minimalists comm
and you'll also receive our simple
Sunday emails each week for our added
value this week besides the Joc a
willing thing that Ryan mentioned
earlier we have one more added value
this week here's a song from one of the
best songwriters alive his name is
Jeffrey Foucault now he has a new album
out called Blood Brothers and I don't
really know how to describe it it's not
blues music
it's not country music it's not folk
music it's not singer-songwriter music
it's sort of all of those things and
none of those things at once I love his
music because it's it's pure poetry and
it's beautiful song right it's some of
the best writing there is period and by
the way it's great music as well so here
is here's a song my favorite song of his
in fact it's one of my favorite songs of
all time it's called northbound 35 by
Jeffrey Foucault if you enjoy it you can
check out his new album Blood Brothers
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus